[Musica]
non può trasportare
la fate a chi liberamente
[Musica]
berruti
sostanzialmente una nuovissima è sempre
un bomber da te un po sono seduta lì
belle come si chiama il pillolo perdenti
da oggi dovremo fare da un nuovo
dentista cattivo tra un altro perché ai
20 con la domanda diciamo voi che fate
menti dei dentisti sono tutti i tiranni
che tutti o quasi tutti
scappare la vetta rovetti prum del
dentista come sempre mettetevi comodi
prendendo i pop corn e le regioni e con
il nuovo desista si chiama bob
sei pronta per l'estrazione del tuo
dente ma quello vietare ma non c'è uno
spazzolino c'è una scopa per pulire il
cammino
peccato dammi il momento per estrarre il
dente cattivo dove sta andando ok io
direi di scappare via ok adesso che se
ne è andato a scampia nord che un crono
la chiave sono questi ecco questi sono
tutti i denti gratuito i
propri commenti dei tech sta facendo una
collezione di poi gli danno una dentiera
omaggio
dovrei proviamo a fare presto
ok ora che abbiamo trovato la chiave
quali lasciate mandare alla
attenta primo prezzo non ci credo io
sono già avantissimo stavo per dire
infatti ma dopo tutto questo tempo
sarebbe ancora bravi a nostra giovani
cinesi come facevamo fatti abbiamo perso
un po la molla mai ma si vede perché di
solito mercato col piede in terza
vediamoci censis precederà più anita
vitale ora queste dentiere times primo
finita perché tempo landola sto per sé
perché ho imparato molte cose
possiamo alla porta di dell'ufficio che
vogliono stare lassù furto ma non
succede niente si è aperta che succede
no la mia porta non sia aperta come
chavez continua a insiste dobbiamo
camminare su questa specie di tubo
bianco erano video su youtube iac roma
come non vedere sul tubo bianco dai
dentro prova deve trarne un prodotto è
ok ma vorrei scriviamo è seduto rimedi
sulla scala con un super verità smetterò
di butera roma sarebbe il filo
interdentale e lo so forse forse invece
tu vuoi che porta l'acqua le macchine
perché ci sono gli scultori sbrighiamoci
di più e voi avete lasciato un mi piace
questo buio miracoloso state o mi piace
qua sotto così ci porterete anche
fortuna per arrivare non si è presentato
16 suono bordi strano allora che cosa
dice qua a tempo l'animale di bob cioè
nel senso all
animale del cucciolo attento al cucciolo
di bob ce la vediamo quale del cucciolo
di poco
[Musica]
una ventina
una dentiera con l'occhio davanti così
poco mesi era il cucciolo di poterla
dimettere ma proprio una dentiera a
credere che vi quota e poi c'è una
verità non so dove dobbiamo andare i
prof
inseguendo te li abbia via via renzi sia
la strada giusta c'era scrivendo la cosa
fa non ho fatto in tempo a leggere che
cosa ci aspetta
ma chi no io chiamo tardi arriva male tu
avanti un mio tempo dei labirinti mi
piace il mio outfit con orecchi da volte
maglietta arrivi come quella che si
conclude poi gli orecchi non si vedono
ma sono gli stessi che ho adesso con le
fragole e gonna rota e calze bianche e
gialle mi piace gli ospiti di oggi
bocciato la riuscita mia vita ne è
uscita molto raro che sei andato avanti
da sorbillo offerti sempre ma allora chi
ci sono delle ventole delle eliche tv
bisogna passarci in mezzo del condotto
di areazione con secondo voi perché
l'italia non si è sfracellato perché ho
troppo bravo come non detto
regali privo di evitare democratiche il
belgio si si guarda te sono io ciao ciao
per noi verremo mangiati da bob o non
come le altre skype room poi non male
avevo pensato
mangiate ma chi ci sta ci vado
mi sono scocciato
tutti sono aggiornato formativo sbaglio
che ci sono queste grate elettrificate
sono dei laser
viaggio aspettavo perché devo aspettare
si va avanti
via frigia l'ho fatta quindi
macellato e avete visto frazionamento e
digitale ha comuque costumisti capo di
cambiare i pantaloni e
mi faccio mancare dovuta nella
misura quasi plumbea vedete l'italia
dimenticata di metterti le mutande e
amore pantaloni bucati
spesso in avanti via ascensore accettare
come circolare che vola
sui fatti
ho preso coscienza di quello prima
in alto ed altro è scendere qua è
capitale
o no mi sembra ci sia della lava
stranieri colorati insistito
si sono cementate tutto
ok allora penso di avere ora un voi
ditemi cosa c'entra con il dentista che
certo si sa che è un dentista sempre un
pavimento di lava non sono stato io
questo modello di leggi vigenti colorati
per cento ok
forse porta quasi a porta che cosa ho
trovato che cosa si trovasse il trenino
della miniera nel sotterraneo del
dentista è che trenino quando vieni
vabbè adesso cominciamo
devo prendere il treno e superare vitale
pochi non risposi di qua dove viene qui
trenino
breve allora concentrazione è
un uomo molto conosciuto perché se
mostrerà gli occhi così come se fosse
una bara
quadrino
faticare mi sembra che davanti a me si
queste reti siamo in un segreto del
dentista ha certo è normale che non ci
sono stabia anche un caffe solo wifi e
lo devo dire con lo spazio né
lo spazzolino con le punte quindi un po
ea tema dai allora coabitare credo detto
no a tanti poligoni e si può passare da
qui
appunto che sfiori anche un pochino
queste piattaforme ghini sprazzi ricordo
che io già lo so infatti subito avanti
io mi sono sfracellato solo una volta
eletto invece millemila
cosa è successo nel frattempo lui ci
sono arrivato alla super velocità ok
supervelocità abbiamo adesso
mi sono sfracellato anch'io che questa è
la mia occasione per super eto'o no
no anch'io mi sono stragelato
ora prende tenere in costa
vi porterebbe su per evitare
che c'entra che ti avanti magari chi
sfracelli adesso
si
guarda porti sfiga
no resta gli ultimi due anni mancano
sono tutti e due solo uno no non posso
rimanere bloccata in questo stage dove
vicar e dietro di te va bene lavoravo
anche la possibilità di superarlo
massaggiava dio
non è detto perché potresti espresso il
latte o no non mi dire così
in fumo porta ce l'ho fatto solo volte
non ci credo ma l'ho fatto anch'io
finalmente
[Musica]
ok non lo so perché sono evitando
cioè decidere e o anche supera subito o
solo bruno devo trovare le fece scritto
no però non va bene selezione alla fine
mini superi così riguardo sono stato
sempre in vantaggio e
come leno presto vediamo che succede
non è successo niente dove dove sei
minuti vedono aiuto extra
leva e poi portesine solo una ancora e
vediamo che succede
compriamo grande e mezzo prima di
evitare il nodulo basta devo andare
contro questo muro è trovato un po
come o di scappare da me bob è
arrabbiato bauer attacca mamma
papà mamma mia che brutto perché
riproviamo
politici dati lui devo fare dove andare
dove
dobbiamo trovare la strada allora vi amo
seguire questi i denti io sedute
[Musica]
bob ragione dico
ok riproviamo allora ho già preso
proviamo andare tutto dritto
o
[Applauso]
anche solo solissimo
riproviamo per l'ennesima volta che
stavolta mobiliterà il botto banchetto
con cui debito rallentano
ok allora andiamo quadri dietro sui
denti
funziona è tornata la fiat non ci credo
fossero io gigante la moto perché sono
gli gigante e poi c'è una porta segreta
quando mi dire che hai preso il match
prima di me in realtà non è bello ma non
ci pensa che forse devo aspettare
evitare perché il compagno belle ma come
hai fatto
ok ok
a testo di seneca
che siamo riusciti a scappare
ci ha portato da un'altra parte centrale
trasportato dice che la scuola dei
bisogni e cube di qb cosa quindi
dentista già trasportato in questa
scuola degli incubi vediamo cosa ci
aspetta eccomi ma ci sono anch'io solo
che a me non funziona il mouse
ma perché qui non funziona ma che me
dicendo allora vediamo com'è fatta
classe perché io mi muovono il tuo
computer ma non finivo e cosa
vabbè
evitare il battito
questo dovrebbe essere un robot cattivo
della scuola degli incubi pensa che
siamo qua vediamo un po come questa
taglia grande richiamo io adoro le skin
rubata a scuola vitale purtroppo è stato
il blocco del minato da bob
non billiton noble e quindi qua i bulli
non possono entrare ognuno potrebbe
allora andrà tutto bene no queste porte
soprattutto più uscito perché mi
ingranare anita tories e la classe c'è
la lezione non è ancora finita
ma siamo ingenito questo professore
aiuto che questo è il mio secondo te
questa insegnate tecnologia
aiuto
non vorrei andare di massa con due o kay
riproviamo allora non dovevo andare là
quindi proviamo qua ma mai microspie
fratelli portato prodotti proprio a dare
4 giu non mi dire che un vicolo cieco
ma diventa un po difficile per stare
alla fine del video scriveteci nei
commenti qual è stata la vostra ski
promo preferita questa
dell'insegnante degli incubi oppure bob
il dentista quindi guardate il video
fino alla fine perse granfondo etnica
ok nel frattempo vita tempo non tornare
nel gioco va tanto all'originaria
scappare
insomma comunque sì ho conosciuto
anch'io il professore ha ruggito dai
proviamo a capire assieme
li ho proprio la strada tutta dritta ma
una lite questo lascia quasi era una
sorta chiusa quindi devo girare un nuovo
bisogno sinistro però
tutto questo siamo qui per me comincia
addio hanno ingerito al ruggi riusciti
pure
io allora qui ci sono delle impronte di
mano a qualcuno è passato a tesi che
scuola strana questa
chissà che cosa sta facendo qua sotto
qualche esperimento se gli amici ma le
rinunce giganti hanno non solo delle che
minaccia solo dei tubi non cadere miano
vado siamo arrivati fino a qua non
cadere perché sono bisogna fare tutta
una china mancato poco
dice di premere questo pulsante c non
c'è un problema si premuto e adesso
reset
forse ho capito perché dobbiamo prendere
la scala è metterle una sopra l'altra
per salire questo però chiaramente forse
ok ok
bastano due scatole cai nolente
io ti vedo così senza si entra per mano
ten sicura che sei pregiate ma ritengo
siano niente
dai basta l'ho beccato deflazionistico
ma non so perché mi cade ecco mi debba
ma butt o no l'ho fatta a me troppo
lontana non ci arrivo
casarano decimi di grado 3 anni davvero
ok
che signor preso sfruttamento no
scherzavo quel coso mi ha preso dieci
volte speriamo che alla fine dobbiamo
affrontare il robot arrugginito come
abbiamo fatto con la nonnina me di
karate la scorsa escape from buche con
la nomina che sparava anzi no più avanti
si considera abbia solo perché ci
abbiamo provato in biscotti bat potete
aspettava stata totale se l'avete vinta
andate poi a vederlo dopo questo video
sia della casa e divinità dalla fine era
troppo divertente peccato che non si
potevano mangiare biscotti però se
rimane di tutti e poi c'è qualcuno qua
ma qualcosa treno che c'è qualcuno
perché era così deserto vediamo premiamo
qua che succedesse
macchinato qualche cosa non lo so
l'elettricità dice sono faccino vedere
se quella pagina bianca ovvero gli
attori oppi inquietante hanno visto una
pagina bianca di aver offerto a casa e
cliccare da ottima che brutta audio
serie qua comincia a salire di nuovo
bisogna spostare le scatole vittoria
dato che va dove c'è quell'altro
giocatore immobile che non so perché non
ho capito dove sei sono a ok
c'è mancato poco vediamo un po cosa si
aspetta sono qui su una scala proprio
dietro
ma che a scuola che bello
e cosa mi dice che ho solo dietro di te
qual quale dobbiamo scappare anche
qualcosa di più e allora ci sono queste
porte chiuse c'è un'atmosfera strana
quanto
ho visto che si è sparato in aria e tipo
e anche questo tipo l'animaletto del
robot ma io scappando ancora non è preso
nessuno è una sorta di permetto a ragno
roma un però ma che cos'è guarderanno
robot tra poco lo scoprirai sede tutto
questo con trovato nessuno fondando
avanti che brutta beni a
questa è la strada notifiche questo lo
tradiva
cielo freccia come stessero braida è
vero niente sto correndo giusti con noi
roma nulla ok riproviamo adesso sappiamo
qual è la strada ha davvero
anche se
è male come non ti ricordi no proprio
una buona memoria ferri i luoghi cioè
non so dare le indicazioni stata
immigrazione anche nella città in questo
neonato o l'altro ho vissuto tanti anni
fa vide mi sento per voi e questi ma non
mi ricordo niente vari tifosi delle
strade o
in parte meno male che ho seguito io non
so prima vedi anche se non ho nessun
senso dell'orientamento sono riuscito a
portarti in libertà insomma io motivo
e tu te ne approfitti faccia anche un
altro giocatore ciao ciao c'è scritto
qualcosa nei muri c'è scritto stanno
arrivando e vattene ok equa nessuna
bugia che sono forse i professori qui ci
credo quei robot a ok qui c'è scritto
solo per gli insegnanti
quindi noi entreremo il braccetto
venissero questi che non ho capito che
cosa è successo mi sa che mi hanno preso
una di queste palle mi ha preso
a c'è scritto stanno guardando ho capito
sono dei robot tipo i professori sono
dei robot
senza qua in questo bisogna abbiamo
allora piano non svegliate perché
l'ho sognato ma
mi ha fatto spaventare
[Musica]
un po trasporta
bella però questo schifo non mi piace
perché pauroso sapete che adoro questo
paulon e a proposito di cose paurose
avete già mio libro storie poste
iscrivetevi commenti se l'avete già
finito di leggere
riproviamo allora questa volta dobbiamo
andare molto paga for secondo me allora
si accorgono se tu vai veloce 10 in più
non ti devi avvicinare quindi devi
scegliere la strada
secondo me quando sei troppo vicina devi
saltare come in questo caso tipo salta
per uccidere ma che forse abbiamo capito
come fare ce l'ha fatta
[Musica]
allora c'è scritto trova i tre bottoni
ok o no allora 11 sarà questo qualcosa
mi dice
la pressione marmetto che mi ha frullato
ok allora dobbiamo trovare i bottoni nel
frattempo siamo pure eseguiti da via
questi mostri
allora ho trovati molto libero dove
donne ma qui su quel che così
lo trovavi che cosa bisogna fare allora
si può salire sopra questi spalti forse
qui sopra non salgono la predetta allora
potremmo dividere button e ho trovato
più un bottone visto che mi avevi
trovato tre non lo so questo trovato
aiuto ho trovato aprire un bottone
proprio qui perché proprio tre le
portava uno allora 1 e là sopra
come la sovra lì allora questo ti dica
quanti bottoni premuto non ne ho trovate
lì è stato un altro che il comune
ok lo premuto el'altro stato dall'altra
parte e adesso ci manca il terzo con
saic amodeo ha detto abbiamo trovato
tutto è perso è vero
mi chiede manca solo una
ha preso allora fai così si aspettano
secondo te lo dico io
salì subito a 1 ma questo già famosa
allora ci sono già promette
che cosa io lo mettiamo remoti prodotti
tutti e tre devo dire che anche se ci
hanno preso tool ebbe molti 23 e credo
di aver premuto il tasto detto wow
suscitare rabbia
scritto cool youtubers
aperte sia motivi youtubers
sono come una pera mi dispiace per te ti
definisce gioco di squadra adesso
primi peggio vince
così aiuto il vino in vantaggio offrono
è giusto devo recuperare
le in testa ma ora lo superò questa è la
parte più difficile
dio
che è figo che ascoltare il musino
credere o no e l'ho già passato ciao
ponte
un'altra po no attendo che ci sono casi
ce ne sono alcune che si rompono le di
essere veloce a meno male stiamo
ricominciando la hall pongono connubio
ben insomma velocissimo che c'è un vero
scoprirai presto subito lì che cosa è
successo
esatto
bega mister nightmare norvega mister
incubo
allora io me te quante difficoltà che
dobbiamo come si fa annunciò la testa
bellissimo intorno così con una specie
di laser lab a
spararla con il fucile
ne ho preso anche un action rajavi è
difficilissimo prenderlo molto e anche
scappare
ma come sempre
mater si ok centro che di tu anche se
capri con il nostro sulla delibera lo
stesso è forte di noi
no scherzavo a spendere la cifra
ok siamo quasi non so come fortemente
vero è pure gli occhi laser super
complicato allora guarda forze aiuto
aiuto se scatti se scappi tipo da qui da
dove allora proviamo prima ad
avvicinarci il più possibile
appare incredibile one quanti abruzzo
che ha preso noi no non c'entra giù come
andare l'arma e non c'è larghi ma se ti
avvicini se ti avvicini forse riesce a
prendere l'arma da qualche parte si fa
ci sono ricevo
ok ho preso l'arma coerenza prevede lo
studio di avvicinare e poi dopo devi
scappare ok
io provo a colpirlo da qui vediamo
allora vediamo che tu ne sei così sono
però deve prima prendere l'arma
tipo no avvicinati al punto di salto
no sono caduta gioielli fate un salto e
poi tornare indietro quasi scontato
nel frattempo store vista silos
conflitto
e questa sera devo dire che
prima non è ancora detto perché no paolo
trapani sorridendo
figo un fa ma io quando mi avvicino e lo
chiamano che può prova non ci credo sei
riuscito a prenderlo
bravo nei preso o
sei stato molto in prime time il
programma volo basso tu hai trovato un
trucchetto fantastico io
sappiamo uscito autista posso abitare io
non c'e nessun artista che è uno dei
premi ok guai davvero andando
meglio ma tutti primo round in chiamo
che belli ci aspetta però tu sei stato
molto bravo perché lei sconfitto senza
trucchi atene e ora speriamo evitare
che cosa sono queste
[Musica]
finalità gigante
come questo che la vostra preferita la
mia preferita è stata questa la seconda
a meno che ci è piaciuto di più quello
del dentista ora come ora siamo passati
da squalificare per vedere i nostri
altri vivi al capitolato preferita